The number of children who had come to America seeking asylum that have since
been detained has exploded to the highest number ever recorded.
More than 5 times higher than just last summer.
Of the 2,654 children separated by the Trump administration’s zero-tolerance policy,
136 are still in U.S. custody without their parents.
Three of them are under 5 years old, and the parents of 96 of those children have already been deported.
Mami, I know you’re crying, and I’m sorry. I’m sorry.
I’m sorry. I’m sorry. I’m sorry. I’m sorry.
Hundred times I’m sorry. We love you, and we love your children.
We will do something. I promise you, we'll do.
We’re strong together, yeah?
We. Will not. Be silenced.
[crowd cheers]
This summer, hundreds of grandmothers traveled from all over North America to the U.S. border with Mexico in McAllen, Texas.
[Crowd]
Shackling them like slaves.
Day two with the grannies on a bus.
Day three. I'm here with Rachna.
At the moment, emotions are playing too much. I don't know what to think. Every time I'm looking at something, I feel like crying.
And every time I look at something, I feel there's hope.
We joined the original caravan in New York City and made stops at detention centers all across the country.
These grandmothers wanted to see with their own eyes what was happening.
Their message of compassion and their appeal for common-sense immigration reform resonated all along the way, until the final stop in McAllen, Texas.
The first grandmother we met was Rachna, a natural-born storyteller.
[Rachna]
If I prick you, you're gonna bleed the same color blood that I am, and if you're lucky enough, matching blood for you will be found when you need it.
Right?
[laughter]
Sitting alongside Rachna in a cramped van for eight days, I would quickly be reminded of just how much more we all have in common than there is that divides us.
Equally likely that, in that refugee camp, in that internment camp, there is somebody with your same blood group.
Right or wrong?
- Right.
So how are you any different from them?
God made us the same. We are the ones who have put the divisions.
You are gonna love Rachna.
- OK. [laughs]
- Really, Rachna is something else.
That's great.
How do you say it again?
- Pardon?
How do you say your name again?
Rach-na.
- Rachna. OK.
I am Rachna. I have four grandchildren.
It's easy and it's hard. It's easy when you're saying it. Ten minutes later, “What the hell was it?”
Call me whatever you want, but with a smile. If you're frowning, if you frown and say ... Even if you got it right, I didn't hear you. [laughs]
Smile and say it. It's easier. [laughs]
The first one I met was Anne, in New York.
[Anne]
I feel like I should go and talk with Ellie.
- OK.
- So if you will keep an eye?
- I will keep an eye on things. I'm very good at sitting down.
[Ahmed]
She was actually very good at a lot of things.
You know me, giving me a mic to talk ... I love it ... any day.
She loves to talk on the mic.
- Surprise, surprise, right?
I'm surprised that people want to hear me. My kids would be surprised ... I really love talking!
My grandmother was an immigrant. My parents were immigrants. I became an immigrant when I came here.
In India, I was born in India.
For so many of the grandmothers, their personal stories of discrimination, of prejudice and hatred in its ugliest forms, is what eventually motivated them to go on this journey.
As parents and grandparents, it is our duty to make the world a safer place.
[Speaker]
You know, my background is that I'm a secular Jew, and part of my identity is that I need to stand up and fight for justice.
[Rachna]
When I saw these children, the pictures of them hiding behind their mothers, the mothers looking so desperate ...
It brings back memories. It brings back conversations which I've had with my grandmother, with my father, with extended family members.
It comes back to you.
The whole world is one big family. Because when my ancestors were refugees, it was people who were supposed to be the enemy country ...
Muslims who were helping my family to cross safely.
You're saying we're all one family?
- Yes, we are.
So we could be, this could be a family portrait?
- It is a family portrait! What do you mean could be? It is a family portrait!
So let's take it. Ready? Family portrait.
On day two, Rachna met Edith, her host in Pennsylvania.
[Rachna] You do a lot of driving, Edith?
- No.
[Rachna] If you don't mind me asking, what is your age?
- My age?
- If you don't mind me asking.
I'm 94.
- Wow.
[Edith]
Growing up in Nazi Germany, I saw what can happen when enough good people don't do anything.
My mother and I were sent off to Auschwitz.
We got to the railway station, and kicked everybody out of the train, and we walking along the station, and there's a German officer ...
And he said to my mother, "You go that way," and to me, "You go that way.”
And I said, "But that's my mother." And he said, "Well, you'll see her in 20 minutes. She's going on the bus, and you'll be walking."
Well, that's the last I ever saw of her, and then ... It took me days to find out what happened to the people who had gone to the other side.
They were sent to the gas chambers.
[Rachna]
God bless you. God bless you. It's so sad that we human beings haven't learned anything.
[Edith]
I feel we have to get involved, and people ... You can't stand by and not do anything.
[Rachna] So we're going this long way to give those children love, right?
- Yep.
We're going to give them so much love, and they need to know that there's love waiting for them. They need to know that.
[Dan]
This morning, though, we're going to be seven vehicles and a motorcycle. Plus Tim, here.
So this is Dan, he came up with the entire idea of going on this trip.
I just wanted to, like, have a moment where we – not a prayer, per se.
- Raise our spirits and show America that we were here, we will love, and ...
Dan is paternal. He's patient. And he's pissed off.
I couldn't get the image out of my head of my own 3-year-old being in a cage, and just like ...
It's one thing to have prisoners, but children as prisoners ... Children have so many needs all the time.
Would he be trying to, like, talk to another 3-year-old in the next cage?
Would he be asking the other 3-year-old where his mama is?
So after watching the shocking news unfold, as the Trump administration began separating children from their families,
Dan took to Facebook and asked if a group of grandmothers might want to drive down to the border with Mexico.
I hadn't been able to cry it out or anything. I had been like, all ...
tight about it, and then I watched that Rachel Maddow segment, where it was like ... The news in the world was so f*cking bad, a journalist couldn't report it, you know?
[Rachel]
Trump administration officials have been sending babies ... to at least three ... [cries]
three tender-age shelters in south Texas. Lawyers and medical providers ...
I think I'm going to have to hand this off. Yeah ...
[Dan]
It was like centers are babies are detained ... in jail ... She just ... I'm gonna cry again.
That segment just set me off so bad, I literally fell to the ground. I got on my knees and sobbed out a week’s worth of crying that I wanted to do.
Cuz I was picturing my Henry.
Yeah, my 3-year-old.
It's sick.
[Racha]
You know, in the news, there's so much about hatred, about how much every community seems to be fighting and hating the other community.
But we were so many grandmothers, and so many youngsters, also. From all different parts of the country.
And there's so much nonsense about, “This is fake news, and that is fake news." I am seeing for myself what is actually happening.
I've read it in the news, and it hurts me that human beings can treat each other that way, especially educated, caring human beings. And we are, aren't we!
It wasn't just that Rachna had all the answers. She also somehow had all the right questions, too.
[Rachna]
I heard people saying that these people don't deserve it. What do you mean, "these people"?
We're all people. In what way are you different from the person over there?
[Rachna]
In what way? You both have two eyes. You both have one heart. You both have that one brain.
How much you use it is a different story ... But still, one brain, right?
Reunite. No child can be hurt. There's no question of your child or my child or his child. No. They're children, and that's all that matters.
So we just crossed the border from Brownsville, Texas, into Mexico. As you can see under this blue tarp, these are some of the people who are going to be seeking asylum.
They tell us that they're waiting their turn. They were told that they have to come back because it's too busy.
[Racha]
I was looking this side at the beautiful sunset and wondering when the American Dream became an American nightmare.
Because that's what it feels like to me.
Feels like a nightmare.
[Coughs]
We are America the beautiful. Why are we destroying it?
We should be proud everybody wants to come here, all the hardworking people want to come here.
Uplift us. Join hands with us.
[coughs]
I'm not sick - this is all emotion coming out.